remembrance 100 has been a remarkable
success a time to recognize and reflect
on those people who sacrificed their
lives for our freedom the men and women
from every corner of our fine country
whose grit and determination defended
our democracy and rights a reason for
anyone with a shred of respect for our
outstanding nation to feel proud to the
people suggesting that this year is a
moment for a final commemoration I say
this should be the benchmark for
remembrance the foundation for restoring
pride respect and dignity back into our
failing society we're living at time
when our kids are struggling for proper
role models a teachers want to abandon
anything mentions conflict remembrance
100 showcased the real heroes of society
and it reminds us that there's never
been peace unless it was fought for why
should we remember we remember those
heroes that came home and can't ever
forget we remember those heroes that
never came home so that we could keep
ours lest we forget
[Music]
fill your sentiments of stirring and
moving and I hope viewers haven't
adjusted your set because I see you've
still got your remembrance poppy do you
which is good and I join you and I
probably the rest of the panel and the
country in thinking though the way this
country and the royal family and our
dignitaries celebrated from a hundred
years since armistice was fantastically
powerful overwhelmingly moving moving
and beautifully done but it was now a
hundred years ago and the reason we
started having these celebrations or
commemorations was because most of these
villages and communities had really lost
someone they knew someone they had lost
but now we're moving into an era where
we don't have any personal connection
with those who died in the First World
War and so my question to you is this
really I think we need to keep
Remembrance Sunday but should it be a
bigger should we remember those who have
died in all
absolutely not just leave it was
armistice so how on earth do we top what
happened a hundred years after the end
of the First World War
absolutely and there was wars before
that as well don't forget okay so I'm
remembering I'm remembering but I'm fine
fine I'm remembering all the men and
women throughout history who've done
what they believed was right for the
democratically at that time elected
government okay
and so armistice call it what you like a
hundred years ago but I will remember
for the rest of my dying days on his
planet everybody who's made that
sacrifice okay if I can just I mean we
can take a cue on that Rachel from the
remembrance as often the commemoration
of the Holocaust where what they then
started doing the Holocaust Memorial
Trust is they started adding other
genocides on the same day and so when I
went to one of those just outside
Westminster actually just outside house
of parliament
they had some survivors from the Bosnia
genocides some Muslims standing next to
Jews remembering the Holocaust and the
Bosnian genocide they brought people in
from Rwanda so I think there is a case
there to expand the remit of this
particular issue is people Malaya and
conflict you know it doesn't the one
year when a British soldier hasn't lost
his life and I just come here from the
counter-arguments from a leading thinker
who argues instead of remembering we
should forget and that Simon Jenkins in
The Guardian and he says enough of
Remembrance Day we really ought to get
over it almost all the conflicts in the
world are caused by too much remembering
it sustains ongoing disputes and
encourages people to keep alive old
feuds Britain should write the Wars of
the 20th century into its history books
and then move on this man is just is are
just his words say the way if he didn't
mean to offend me you have son you want
absolute completely now a turbocharged
fall as far as I'm concerned and there's
absolutely nothing more I ever want to
sing from you ever written in any paper
anyone this planet
I'm not going to stand on the fence on
that one even deal with that can I just
say and I agree with you to a point so
I've thought the proceedings in France
were absolutely breathtaking and to see
all of those world leaders together and
to see the Allies alongside their former
phones coming together United to honor
those who have lost their lives so I
don't want to sort of be debbie downer
but what we ruined the mood was the way
President Trump behaved and the fact
that he didn't go and visit the American
soldiers and I think with what you're
saying if our leaders aren't actually
celebrating and honoring those who have
died in the way that you're talking it's
hard to then get the whole nation behind
interesting the Simon Jenkins for the
Guardian was a young Trump side of that
debate can I just quickly go to a the
unite so this is a German ambassador
what he says is the memory of the first
world war is fast receding into history
people are forgetting how terrible it
was we have a responsibility not to take
peace lightly or it can be taken for
granted it's precious and can be lost
and I think here in response to Simon
Jenkins quite I think the point is not
so much that people are no longer alive
that participated in the great war but
that actually it was such a terrible and
tragic war to have embarked upon and the
cost was so high that we do need to
remember that - that supposed to be the
war that ended all wars in it and yet it
didn't can I just we look at the head of
the Armed Forces engagement at the Royal
British Legion see what he says and I'll
give you my view I think the First World
War is indelibly marked on our national
conscience so I think this it will
always be alive in our monuments in our
in our history and in the fabric of our
very nation but I think what we need to
do moving on is to start really focusing
on making remembrance relevant to all
generations and to all audiences yeah
and I agree with him so I always like to
go and watch a March or something on
Remembrance Sunday not for me to
remember a specific incident but I see
it as a way of showing respect I see it
as a way of showing respect to people
whomever you know whichever war is that
have died but
also a sense of gratitude as well two
people that have got the the bravery in
the courage that still serve today and
that's what Remembrance Sunday means to
me it's not about going back and looking
at particular event it's about a period
a period of time which culminates in
that that day for me to actually press
pause on what I'm doing and just say a
sign thank you yeah gratitude and
everything I absolutely appreciate a
mission and I say for me you know I'll
close my eyes and I think to the guys
that didn't come back to me all right
and that's hard all right okay and the
guys that did make it out the other side
what we could see a very big one you'd
film thanks bringing it up now that's
nearly it for this week but before we go
there's just time for this whether
you're whether it's introducing yourself
to her colleagues dad only to find out
he's her husband or congratulating a
friend of a friend on her pregnancy when
she's really just carrying an extra bit
of timber we've all made a few social
faux pas in our time but for most of us
it doesn't involve two world leaders and
it's not being filmed by an
international news channel however one
101 year old woman managed just that
this week when she mistook German
Chancellor Angela Merkel for the first
lady of France
for Gandhi Gandhi
and that's why she's our straight talker
of the week
well mrs. Mac on the actual would have
been fuming do you think um so what is
Michael I keep repeating it there's
really you know there's any doubt yeah
101 know that limiting